標股在線等 黃金交叉
即將開課喔
今天一堂課讓你KD全都懂喔
看一張圖情就可以賺錢了
短的線你也可以做到三成
長線你也可以做到五成
黃金交叉我又買
對 然後這個地方跌破五均了
我又買
你就一直巴著他不放
一直吃他的豆腐
這搖錢術耶
台積電外資喊500
所以他如果這邊會不會動畫
蹲... 蹲到500去
只要你的指標是
他就会帮你拉
他就是一个最好的旗长点
从这就要开始涨
再加上KD 你去买
你最少六七成会赚钱
黄金交代的时候买
死亡交代的时候卖
我就可以赚钱了
好 那你是古神
哈哈哈哈
朱老師
我終於等到你了
你好 好久不見
很久不見 對
有十年喔
十年
對
十年前我才剛上國校
十年前
太誇張了
太誇張嗎
我高中剛畢業
你看青梅竹嗎
是
十年前第一次接受你的訪問
十年前全市場
全世界第一個採訪您的就是我
對
我今天來驗證一下
驗證一下說是我對不對
沒錯
很高興十年前妳都訪問
然後十年中間
我們兩個都變化很大
妳從平面走到媒體
那我從教學走到訪問
接受訪問
對 妳已經變成一個很知名的
技術現行的超級名師
對 還要謝謝妳
要謝謝我嗎
對
妳不要謝謝我
因為等一下我會壓榨你
沒問題
因為我知道你上了很多訪問嘛
但是來我們的第一次
我們第一次捷源
所以呢 再回來
要激盪出不一樣的火花
因為你不同了 我也不同了
沒問題
所以我今天要對你煙心靠大了
你要來考考我
來考你喔 以前是你考我喔
是
好 今天的理財大人秀
大家有沒有發現
新的來賓朱家宏老師
到現場囉
我們的朱老師是
K線之神技術分析的名師
那大家可能不曉得
因為現在朱老師很紅
可是十年前朱老師的初到
是為什麼呢
就是因為我啦
就是因為趙華去做了一篇採訪
朱老師十年前是一個非常熱心
非常低調在教學技術分析的老師
那為什麼趙華會發現他呢
趙華發現這個龜寶
那現在呢
我們把他請進了禮財達人秀
開了新單元叫做
標古在線等
強限很多人現在
手上的股票都集在線等
不要擔心
我們會用最前顯入門的方式
讓朱老師把所有關於
技術分析K線的入門指標
一個一個交給你
好我們先來看
不是趙華在胡亂吹牛
好不好
K線之神的第一次
就是給我囉
給了趙華
Munning前雜誌
我進東森前的工作
2011年11月
這樣就漏洩了
上國小應該沒有辦法進雜誌社
李兆華寫了什麼呢
探圖玄古一年賺一倍
花200元當古神
看到
這不是10年前的我啦
這最近
這個是10年以前的朱老師
跟現在一模一樣
也是我現在
200元什麼意思
其實200元朱老師
你真的佛心的創始
因為當時一堂課是四個小時
你只收兩百塊錢
所以趙豪為了採訪你就去上
重點是一堂課四小時
你怎麼那麼佛心啊
因為市場苦人多
賞戶都在賠錢
賞戶都在賠錢 對
那是因為你自己也有一些切身之痛
沒錯沒錯
所以想說
我們以前賞戶也是
當賞戶也是在賠錢
那學類技術分析之後
才發現技術分析是一塊寶
你把技術分析學會了
在圖上就可以找到黃金屋
你要再拿買再拿賣都很清楚
最近大家很感受很多標股
對
標的一塌糊塗
在現等
那請問你怎麼敢買
就是因為有張圖
因為他沒有基本面
因為我看基本面
我根本不敢買
有的很多沒基本面還賠錢的
對不對
但是我們看一張圖
你就可以賺錢了
好 所以我們用一個術語
叫做理財達人秀
現在跟我們的標股之神
標股在線等 黃金交叉
即將開課
現在還要多頭排列
多頭排列
還有沒有 就是量價俱養
好 我們來看一下
我們的標股民師朱家宏
也是我們的技術分析之神
上校軍官變成了K線之神
這個喔 趙華在採訪你的時候
還鬧了一個烏龍
那時候我寫上位
哇 一堆人打電話來說
你把男生的軍階弄錯
這很糟糕的事情耶 很嚴重耶
上校軍官是聯合跟你道歉
那時候已經退休了
已經退休了
沒關係 如果還在軍中這樣子
就被降級了
好 所以是上校
而且57歲
老師 你現在不才47歲嗎
你57歲學會是未來事
看線圖抓標古的戰法
然後從此再骨海翻身
累積千萬資產
這個客氣這個每個來的達人
都客氣沒關係
記報酬有兩成 年賺一倍
老師其實很強調
擅長技術分析要短線波段操作之外
最重要的是技術操作
所以我們今天技術分析的第一堂課
要教大家最耳熟能詳的兩個字
兩個英文
KD
常常聽到對不對
KD什麼黃金交叉啦
KD值站上多少要賣啊
KD到底是什麼
KD學會的真的有妙用嗎
今天一堂課讓你KD全都懂
所以老師 你要拿出你的戰機來了對不對
好 我們大家來看一下
這一張圖是今年的
我今年4月份去做的
然後到7月10號
也就是上上個禮拜
好 前一陣子了
對 那長線已經有五成的獲利了
你一計短的線你也可以做到三成
長線你也可以做到五成
為什麼可以
我們就看這張圖你就知道
我在這裡買 在這裡
我在這裡買 在這裡賣
在這裡你買 在這裡你賣
在這裡你賣 在這裡你賣
哇 好像很神喔
不是 主要老師你這樣子
形象有問題
難怪人家都說技術分析
就是一張圖隨便畫
沒錯 我也畫啊
我這裡買 我這裡賣
我這裡賣 我這裡賣
照華也賺53%
沒錯啊
所以你學過技術分析啊
你也賺五成
不是 如果這個這張圖看不出來啦
來 我們來看這一張
你就看出來了
好 這張
哎呦 這張圖啊
我們又看到很多東西囉
對
我們這裡有加上一個KD
那我剛剛講
我說我在這裡買
那各位看KD
KD剛好就是黃金交叉
而且它是一個比較低的地方
沒錯 在50的附近
50附近的黃金交叉
那這裡又是一個旗帳的位置
我們剛剛有講
基礎分析會告訴我位置嘛
這個位置就是旗帳嘛
那你在三天以後
這就到高檔了
所以它就會疊了
所以我們在旗掌再加上KD
你去買
對
買了以後假設你是做短線
那你跌破5均你就賣
這個以後我們再交給
還有期限的概念
對 以後我們會交給大家
怎麼買怎麼賣
好 那今天我們把KD先講
先講清楚
讓你KD了解他的功能
好 那現在他又開始漲了
那KD又黃金交叉
所以我會在這裡買
然後又跌破5均了
我又賣
賣了以後他又上來了
我又是KD黃金交叉
我又買 對
然後這個地方跌破5軍了 我又買
你就一直巴著他不放
沒錯 因為他幫我賺錢
一直吃他的豆腐
這搖錢術
可是就這樣看KDKDKD
KD到底是什麼啊
為什麼KD上上下下
他也跟著上上下下
那我們今天就特別來了解
我們先有個概念
好 有個概念
KD指標
又看到我討厭的人了
製作人俞辰
到底在這邊做什麼
這麼帥你也討厭
這麼帥
你不知道 人不能只看外表
對
好 KD是一個什麼概念
KD的發明人已經有一世紀了
不是有大概60年了
60年以前發明的
那KD指標就代表說
我今天股價 你只看到股價嘛
可是你支付到你的股價高低
就用KD就可以知道了
KD會告訴你的股價高還是低
這好比說
這個製作人
他住在一棟大樓的12樓
那他覺得他住得很高了
高高在上
富貴人家
對
可是他到了樓頂上一看
前面還有比他高的房子
還有一大堆的
這就是一個相對的概念
你只看自己是一個絕對的
可是你跟其他的房子去比
你是相對的 你並不高
所以我們看KD值
他的位置就知道說
現在到底這個股價的
相對位置是高還是低
在低價位還在高價位
那KD的標準的KD
它是用九天來做比較
九天內的比較 九棟房子等等等等
九棟房子裡面有最高的 有最低的
然後我今天的這個價位跟它來比
你就知道你現在是在低價位
還在高價位
很清楚耶 這就是KD指標的一個概念
所以我們用KD指標就知道
你現在買在低檔 還是買在高檔
原來是這個邏輯
所以剛才你看黃金交叉
我就買在低檔
如果跑到上面就會買在高檔
可是低檔跟高檔的數值怎麼判斷
那KD指標很簡單
他就是0跟100中間跑
0跟100
他就在這個上上下下跑
當他跑到20的時候
就表示這個股價跌得很低了
在低檔了
那如果他跑到80了
代表股價在高檔了
就是100層樓對不對
他現在20層樓以下
其實是低樓層
到低樓了
跑到80樓以上就在高樓
跑到101去了
那他給我們什麼概念呢
也就是說如果股價走到80以上
你不要去做多
你不要在這個地方搶著進
可以低值超過80
其實已經有點可怕
高處不生涵了
就是買超過熱
大家追得太凶
買氣太凶了
像這一陣子的生計股對不對
大家一直追到上面已經很危險
好 那多方你就要準備賣了
因為你已經過熱就要回檔了
你就準備賣
那空方 你在這個高的地方做空
你就容易做到
容易 100樓這樣子往下做
現在反過來
如果你是跌得很深了
你多方就準備買
那我們剛剛一看了
黃金交叉大概都在50以下
50 30 20這個地方
那這個地方在低檔
所以你買多
是買在比較低下位的
可是你做空單的人
這已經跌很低了
所以你要準備回補
要回補 不要再踹他了
他已經在地上了
因為已經太低了
他馬上就會談
我們今天錄影最好了
今天我們的合意
生技股今天就漲停板了
所以你如果昨天還去空他
你今天就漲停板了
所以他的KD應該很低的地方
KD已經動畫了
我們等一下後面會告訴大家
動畫喔 專有名次出來了
他已經在下面了
所以我們大概知道KD
最重要的告訴我
股價現在在高檔還在低檔
還是低檔 很重要
這樣子你就會知道
你的操作的策略
我要做多做空
還是多擔體力
還是空難回一步
你就非常清楚
好 所以我們在坊間
對於KD指標
常常會聽到一些術語
相信很多網友捏耳熟能詳
而且你會有一個既定的概念
這個術語出現就是要買
這個術語出現就是要賣
哪些我們來看一下
什麼叫做KD的過熱跟超疊
還有它的交叉跟燉化
最常聽到
第一檔就是KD小於20
高檔就是KD大於80
小魚20當然要買啊
因為很低嘛 對
然後大於80當然要賣囉
好 剛剛老師又提到的
黃金交叉
K線他往上穿破了低線
然後死亡交叉反過來
K線他往下跌破了低線
那當然黃金當然要買囉
死亡我當然要賣
好像很簡單耶 老師
還有就是第一檔燉化了
KD小魚20
而且還持續三天
在地上躺很久
高檔也燉化這個是在天上飛很久
所以他躺很久
我當然要買啊
躺越久好像越便宜
這個高檔都飛那麼高了
我當然要賣
好像被趙華一個人講完了
這堂課交完了耶
這是最基本的概念
但是我們在操作上
當然還要配合很多其他的東西
我們來看一下什麼叫過熱
什麼叫超買 什麼叫超賣
我們先看趨勢
因為趨勢是空
這邊是空
那空頭是不是連續在疊了
你會發現你的指標
已經在20下面
對
那這綠色的這一塊叫動畫
什麼叫動畫就是說
指標因為它在設計的時候
就是跟你九天的比
比如說我跟九天的比
我已經很低了
那理論上我就應該要上來了
要反彈上去
我應該要上樓對不對
那可是骨架還在疊
那怎麼辦呢
都到地下室了
指標就會跑到20的下面
這個就叫動畫了
那在動畫的時候怎麼辦呢
我如果看到動畫
我剛剛有講
第一個你做空單的要準備補了
因為它已經疊得很深了
那你空手的
你就要小心
它就容易這邊反彈
因為這在低檔
它就容易反彈
那如果動畫
我們就不要去看指標
因為指標已經什麼叫動畫
就是他已經頓頓的
是
他沒有辦法反應
那你就不要去管
好 不要去管他
對 你就按照紀律去回補就好了
紅K站上五軍
你把你的空單回補
好 那現在轉成多頭了
你會發現這一路漲
連續漲了五六天
結果指標跑到80的上面了
指標大於80就過熱了
你不要在這裡去追
因為你看你一追他就跌了
他很熱 我如果
他很熱很熱 一直很熱很熱
我現在去追不是應該就會
你追他隨時就會下來
因為表示引進在高大
我以為他已經熱風了
所以我可以進去追一下
這個以後我們交技術分析進場
你就不會在這裡進了
你一定是在下面黃金交叉進
你會在這裡進才會買
對不對
所以這個地方叫燉化
那燉化就不能反應
過熱超過三千
那我們就在上面
按照你的技術分析去出場
因為過熱你就是獲利很多了
對不對 因為操長了嘛
那操長是不是要準備獲利入袋
對
否則再來一個操諜
你就一毛都沒賺到
你這個又跌回來
這時候的心情
其實覺得他會一直漲上去
對 對
所以我們有紀律
到時候你跌破五軍你就賣
那這個在八十以上的這個範圍
我們就叫動畫
所以這時候你就不要去看指標了
好 所以動畫
你可能隨時老師放紅
你就隨時準備停歷了
他跌破五軍了 或者你的紀律
你由人手長線
你就按著你的紀律去停利
好 那我們在這裡就看清楚
指標只要到了動畫都在高檔
你在這裡追是很危險的
其實我們講股市的錢是怎麼來的
是等來的
不是追的
不是喊來的
你追錢就跑了
OK 所以要等
等他回檔
他回檔自然就會
我第一張打開來說怎麼會這麼棒
就是回檔 回檔 回檔
你連做了三次你就賺30%
所以老師有特別強調KD值的妙用
KD其實小優是真的是一個相對的抵擋
相對的抵擋
KD大於80
真的就是相對高檔
所以也不要貪心
覺得他會一直往上走
或是也不要硬凹
覺得他還會往下滴
做股票最重要就是觀念要正確
你不要貪
你一貪
大概就要賠錢了
一股冠頂
所以這是KD值的高低
再來就剛剛講到黃金交叉
跟死黃交叉
黃金因為我們KD有兩條線
一個叫快速線 一個叫慢速線
那快速線跟慢速線
它這個快的穿過慢的
或者紅的穿過藍的 對
而且穿過來以後
兩條線都向上
都還是向上
那這個叫黃金交叉
黃金交叉的意思就是
股價要往上走
兔子超過烏龜
可是烏龜也還在前進走
所以兩條線都是往上的
這時候又是你進場的一個好的餵
好的參考點
好的參考點 對
那死亡交叉就相反了
為什麼會死亡交叉
因為你前面一直漲
你一直漲兩條線就這個嘛
這個就是兩條線就一直漲
這有點像是轉線跟長線
好像都在往上走的意思
兩條線都在往上漲
你的股價也在往上漲
那等於股價跌呢
你這條快的線就開始彎了
對 因為他跑得快嘛
對 那他就先彎
如果你股價繼續跌
它就會出現死亡交叉
慢的也開始彎了
長得就快的先彎下來
那空頭排列行程
骨架就是要疊了
那這時候我們當然要
配合驅使去看
是
如果是多頭
這個當然比較出場了
是
對不對 因為它要疊了
你要獲利入袋了
是
那如果是空頭
這個就準備進場
空它
對 做空
所以我們有指標做輔導
你做多做空
你都還有多了一個
多了一個東西給你參考
是
那為什麼要多一個指標
我們常常講說
那為什麼要學指標
指標是給你加分用的
加分
股票市場 那我總要有基本分
對 基本分就是上面的多空趨勢
你多投做多
又在旗掌的位置
你的成功率已經超過六成
你最少六七成會賺錢
可是我還想更有把握
我想多買一點
萬一沒把握我就不敢
我加上一個指標 你就有八成
老師那你下堂課要教我抓七張點
當然沒問題 那那個是
突然自己想跳課這樣子
一定要的嘛 對不對
因為你要買股票嘛
股票不能買錯位置
那我們買的位置再加上這個指標
讓你的成功率就加高了
老師各位舉例說明
我們來看一下這個例
黃金交叉
好 KD的黃金交叉囉
好 那這支股票各位看得懂嗎
看得懂嗎 我看一下喔
至少如果以kd值來看
這邊相對是比較低
這邊相對比較高 這倒是看得出來
然後是不是短
就是快線穿過慢線
好像也有出現這樣的情況喔
這些地方
這個紅的線穿過藍的
叫黃金叫X 是
可是我們還要看上面
那上面這根k線
剛好就是這個盤整的突破
對 也這裡盤了很久
對啊 盤的密
以後教技術分析
這個叫均線糾結
是
均線糾結突破
就是一個最好的旗漲點
從這就要開始漲了
所以大家回頭看
哎呀 當初買的這多好
看讀書故事
通常你可能買在這
怎麼那麼久啊
就被吸掉
這邊賣掉就上去了
對
好 那我們一樣的話
這個地方是一個黃金交叉
又是有亮的紅K
所以這你開始突破
後面你就做多 這要順勢
假設我這邊真的沒做到
我沒那麼聰明嘛
然後我要確認嘛 就等
下一次機會
所以我們講這個不要去追
你的指標在動畫了
這邊是高檔囉
超過80了 動畫了
你不要追喔
他會回來的
回來之後
洪克長這你又出現黃金交叉
那這時候我們在進場
進場以後他又休息了
休息這你又有一個進場位置
這個叫回檔
回檔之後又攻了
那我今天想買
我再往下看
這個回檔好微弱
這個回檔叫做以盤待疊
以盤待疊
他沒有回
以時間取代的空間對不對
正常就是回
可是他是橫的
所以這個以後我們
菁英斑大概才會討論到
菁英斑會討論到
老師預告我菁英斑
朱老師也會加入我們菁英斑
這個叫以盤待疊
他是盤來代替他回來
所以他在攻的時候
你的指標KD
又變成黃金交叉
他在盤的時候其實這邊
默默的已經下去了
指標已經在修正了
這就是以盤帶這個碟
那他碟 它沒有碟很深
但是它上面有放量漲
然後黃金交叉
這又是一個起工的位置
所以這又工了 又工了
一公里一看 當然
本來他這個地方
因為回檔的很小
所以指標沒有回來很深
我們講抄賣才會回到20
他沒有抄賣啊
沒有耶
對 這也是我的疑問
假設他就是在5、60、60、70
我也會怕怕
好像有點高 因為你上面是旗帳
對 我買在旗帳的位置
所以老師的意思是
我們不是每一次都要等到20
沒有 不是那麼好的
其實你真的等到20
這支多頭不是很強
他反而不是很強的
不是很強才會回到20
對 就是跌得很多
不然怎麼會到20
如果我只跌一天
他不會到20
他大概到5、60就停了
那個叫強勢股
原來如此
老師你解了我心中的疑惑
那以後更是要高級的高級班
我十年前上課沒有專心聽
我一直以為像五六十接近七十
這種還在高檔啊
沒有 我就告訴
我先告訴大家一個原則
對
你今天是這個進場位置
只要你的指標是向上的就OK了
我的紅線 藍線都向上
他就會幫你拉
因為還有一個動畫
還有動畫 表往
他會去動畫
所以老師你目前還是比較提醒
是80以上的高檔動畫
才可能算是高
對 如果60 50
還是會在向上的
會啊 會啊
50 尤其在50的附近
都是很強的
這個地方都很強
因為他會一直漲
而且他可能就是一個強勢股
沒錯 所以這個住股票
在後面都是強勢股
那這個地方是不是又看到
同樣的情形
他又沒回檔 對
這裡又沒回檔
又在椅盤代疊了
他這椅盤代疊
可是指標就沒有回來了
所以我在旗掌的位置
指標又開始多排我就可以進了
所以你還是
但是這裡我會有點怕
因為這邊已經在80了
沒錯
所以你上面有個停立的紀律
停立的紀律
我指標在80表示動畫
動畫代表我股票很強
對
不然他為什麼會動畫
理論上80要下來了嘛
是
那叫很強
所以當很強的時候
我就手上面的K線做記錄就可以
我K線碟破我就買 是
所以有的時候動畫就代表
我們剛才有講動畫
你不要去看指標 對
所以你一看指標
你就會你乾柴亮的
一直都不敢買 對
結果股票一直漲
還有一直漲 OK
所以最重要就是說
這個是以盤帶碟 對
所以它沒有碟
所以指標沒有下來 是
沒有下來它又攻
所以我還是可以去進場
我經常把一些操作的紀律守好就行
好 那我懂了 而且還學到了
就是黃金交叉不要一直在等20
然後說20是超跌
所以20搞不好是弱勢股
有時候5、6時他翻轉向上
翻轉向上 這反而是強勢股的象徵
所以你這一隻等20在這裡
你都沒有等到
對 就在這
後面三坡你都沒有
根本就沒有這一檔的機會了
因為他是強勢股
反過來
死亡交叉我是不是要趕快出場
死亡交叉他一定代表在高檔
死亡交叉他本來一定在高檔
那我現在是在做多嘛
所以你在高檔是不是要準備出
是
那這是黃銀腰差
所以這裡是上漲
老師你找了一檔這麼難的線圖啊
都是一字仙的
那現在是最流行的嘛
最流行的
那我們重點在這裡
死亡交叉是給你建議要賣的
我們看這支股票
最近很多人被套牢了
對 對不對
看被套在哪裡
第一個我們先講你在哪買的
那我們剛才已經教你了
這個叫以盤待疊
對 這一段
然後上漲的時候買
為什麼黃金交叉
好
所以我在這裡買
在這邊買可能買在
260塊錢對不對
對 大概260
好 買了以後它就漲了
所以你指標就動畫了
所以你看這個指標也是很高
也是黃金交叉
對 黃金交叉
到這邊還在黃金交叉
那我買了以後
然後今天出現黑K了
然後你就看指標現在死亡交叉了
對 死亡交叉
所以你在這個買
至少這一根要賣
而且這一根譜賣就賣不掉了
後面就跟你沒關係
這就是我們有一張圖
如果你現在沒有圖
你就用猜的
明天會不會掉
老師這張很可怕
要是你這個紀律沒有守好
後面被關進去了
明天就白做了
對啊
全部都白做了
從最低點他又回來了
你就全部白做
哇
而且就被關關關關關到這邊
可是如果他又打開漲停
那叫反彈
所以要先看趨勢
那這個就是強反彈
你要強反彈是不是
紅K要上漲
這邊要黃金交叉
黃金交叉就可以
所以如果這邊他即時漲停
還沒有呈現黃金交叉
也不要進口場
最好不要等第二天
等第二天他就會黃金交叉
總之就是等黃金交叉對不對
沒錯 那是強反彈喔
這樣的趨勢其實只是一個反彈
因為他已經高檔跌下來
很大一塊
那強反彈就是死黃交叉就跑
你就趕快跑
但老師有提到
如果真的很剛好有放空他的
這邊應該要回補了
要回補了
因為你黃金交叉你比較回補了
這樣子你就應用得很熟練了
你就知道至少我的股票
現在走到高檔來
所以一看到他跌你就跑
對不對 就跑就可以了
所以老師我只要黃金交叉的時候買
死黃交叉的時候賣
黃金交叉的時候買
我就可以賺錢啦
我們來看一下好了
我一檔股票
我不帶往上吃豆腐
來往下吃豆腐
那你是古神
但是我們一講
有的時候你是在做歷史
像剛才強返台是做歷史
歷史 因為他還在疊
不是在談一個而已
你去買多 那是做歷史
那你做歷史就要短線 超短線
歷史就要超短線
那現在我們中和來看一張
好的
這邊是多頭 這邊是空頭
那這樣子你的KD指標去配合
你就比較不會誤導你
否則你會講黃金交叉就買
是你講的 不是我講的
那你剛剛講的
老實來撇清喔
不是黃金交叉就買
要看位階好不好
是你剛剛才講的好奇蹟
現在我們來看一下
這邊是多頭
對
多頭一定做多嘛 對不對
那做多一定要在旗掌的地方買
開市長了
前面都疊嘛
那什麼叫開市長
你就看到他紅K上來了嘛
那這個叫開市長
那這個時候就要黃金交叉
那就好位
而且它是比較偏低的黃金交叉
在50附近
不一定要跑到20來了
好 剛剛有強調了
回檔了 我像下跌了
我這根紅K叫上漲
那我就買
那買黃金交叉很好
你又可以漲一波
那現在黑K下跌又跌了
那這根紅K漲
它又黃金交叉 我又漲一波
所以這波跌息
讓它指標稍微向下
醞釀下一次黃金交叉對不對
因為它只疊了一根黑K
後面就沒疊了
所以這樣子一波 兩波 三波
你都用黃金交叉抓到了
是
現在反過來
這邊是空頭了
以後我們交那個波浪形態趨勢
你就很清楚
什麼是多頭
什麼叫多 什麼叫空
那這邊空頭就只做空了
你就不能做多了
如果你去做多
你看這個紅K黃金交叉
然後就被疊破了
因為你是空頭
所以空頭就看死亡交叉
因為空頭你要做空
如果做空的話
要不然就不理他
要不然你就不要做多
就不要碰他
你就不要做多
好 那個反彈了
你下跌這邊是死亡交叉
所以他就會跌
反彈了 可以下跌嘛
那你去看死亡交叉
死亡交叉是這個地方的第二根
所以這根是我們做空的
所以這一根就死亡交叉
所以這裡做一波 這裡做一波
所以我們從這邊看
KD指標就得了一個結論
大概你就會知道
在多頭裡面看黃金交叉
在空頭裡面看死亡交叉
這是最正確的
那多頭為什麼不要看死亡交叉
因為多頭你的賣點
不是在指標賣的
因為我們一般操作都有個紀律
那紀律都守武軍 守時軍
所以你一定是在均線上賣的
不是在死亡交叉賣的
是 好
所以老師講到一個重點
如果你現在發現股價是多頭趨勢的話
你要做的是黃金交叉的時候買進
但死亡交叉不是你的賣出點
或是空點
因為你會有你自己的紀律
但是如果你發現空頭走勢
那死亡交叉就是你要去空他
或者是你要停利的地方了
好 那現在我們老師
來幫我們做一個總結
我們來總結一下
那就是我剛剛講的
多頭裡面KD黃金交叉
你就是參考買一點
那死亡交叉你就參考一下
你要不要賣
空頭裡面走空頭囉
死亡交叉就是準備做空的
黃金交叉就看你要不要回補
最重要盤整千萬不要亂做
對喔 剛剛我們都沒有講到盤整
盤整可就麻煩
好像股價只有兩種
其實盤整就是叫我們休息
你又做多又做空很累嘛
所以他給你一個盤整
盤整就不要隨便進場
正在我們在操作上
你進場練兩邊被扒
老師標題有錯字了
不準 但是也不準
不準用KT值
這邊你不要用KT值
因為盤整不管黃金或死亡
都不準囉
對 不要用
而且盤整你看什麼都沒用
再來剛剛講的第三件事情
就是頓化了
雖然老師前面已經有透露一點點了
高檔頓話跟低檔頓話的定義
老師幫我們再強調一下
高檔頓話就是
進到80跟100的中間
這個兩條線在裡面
那這時候如果你已經進去兩三天
他都不下來
高檔應該要疊嘛
可是指標不下來這就叫動畫了
那低檔的話疊到20要反彈
他沒有彈啊
他跑到0跟20中間
如果有超過三天
他就再動畫了
那我們剛才也講
動畫就不要去看指標了
因為指標沒有辦法告訴你
現在的狀況
他已經沒辦法表現了
所以我們要回歸股價的走勢圖
還有價量配合
那我們看一下高檔動畫的圖
像這支股票
你看連續漲四 五天漲停板
他早就動畫了
早就動畫了 標太快了
沒辦法漲太多了
所以我剛才有講
你賣的時候
你不要去管指標了
對不對 你一看到碟波五軍
你就賣
因為他已經動畫很久了
已經表示已經操長了
所以我們這邊反而不是用什麼交叉
來決定賣了
我就是可能守無日軍線
或者大家心目中
有一個插操作的軍線
那這邊動畫了
跌破五軍就賣
這邊動畫了跌破五軍就賣
所以你會賣到很好的位置
你基本上就會賣到很好的位置
那反過來就是
第一檔動畫了
他一直跌 這個怎麼反應
這張圖很有趣
因為我跟老師說這是誰
老是說最近低檔頓話的太少了
所以找一個比較久的例子
因為現在大盤都在漲
因為現在沒有什麼低檔動畫
低檔動畫很久了
那你空單要補
你就不要管指標
你看到紅K上來你就補就好了
你就會補在低檔
ok 這叫動畫
老師我們講K低值 K低值
是K值跟D值同時
都要在80或20才叫高檔低檔
叫動畫確認
那個叫動畫確認
其實K值碰到80就在高檔了
可以會先走嗎
可以比較急
而且正常來講
你去看股價就是走三天了
股價連長三天
你的K值就在80
所以我們講不要追三天以上的股票
因為那就是指標在高檔
很危險 很重要
因為散戶通常都是
第一天看不敢追
第二天看很後悔
第三天看就覺得 第三天再去追
第四天就套了
對
那我們KD指標最重要
我剛剛有一講是增加我們勝率的
是
我做多已經很有把握
我指標黃金交叉
那我就更敢買
因為我的勝率很高
對 增加勝率
對 KD指標要配合技術分析
你要做多做空
你要看技術分析
指標沒有辦法告訴你
現在是多空
他只有黃金交叉 死亡交叉
對 我們先把定義學會
對 所以我們去看一下技術分析
然後看現在是多空
還有你的位置長了三天四天
還有軍線懲教量
那這些各位也不要急
日後趙華都會安排
慢慢教給你們
而且會讓你講到
大家都聽得懂
一定聽得懂
然後各位網友們
你也可以盡量留問題問朱老師
因為朱老師佛心來的
他真的教了很多散戶
他的問題
你的問題不管
你會覺得多基本 多入門
多不敢跟告訴別人講
你都可以告訴我好不好
好
KD指標是一個短線的轉折
那以後我們還會有比較看長
MACD也會教
MACD也很重要
它可以看一個長趨勢
那KD指標進場做參考
那高檔動畫
我們就按照紀律出場
我們剛才已經一直強調
考慮你不同的
你做日線就看日線的KD
你做周線你就做看周線的KD
有人做長線嘛
再做周線
那你就看周限的 KG的黃金交叉 死亡交叉
那這個方法跟剛才日線是一樣的
對 老師雖然常常提醒我們短線可能日線
長線可能看到周線月線
但我發現大部分人真的沒看那麼長
包括我自己
對 那以後有機會交長線的時候
再告訴各位怎麼做
糾正一下我們這些人的壞心
能夠把短線抱成長線
好 今天非常謝謝朱老師
那趙立 趙華這邊要來
謝謝我們基因班的同學
而且今天趙華也要非常謝謝
朱家宏老師
因為朱老師10年前跟趙華的相遇
讓我們今天可以之後
進行的壓榨朱老師
所以朱老師也會幫我們上
基因班的課程喔
真的超級超值得啦
我自己都有點不好意思了
那這邊來念一些留言
謝謝你們的支持喔
一個叫應該叫史密
史密說趙華真的很專業
把我們想問的都問到了
覺得加入基因會員很值得
因為我就是散戶
所以我一定知道你們在想什麼
俊傑說金一般真的超佛心
一定會繼續支持的
那現在又有最佛心的朱老師
陳天說每次都結束了才二補
什麼意思
就是你後來才來看
沒有關係
慢慢看要看很多次的
但是節目每集都精彩
比八點檔好看
怎麼會這樣
我覺得啦
你要在股市賺錢
少看連續劇
多看圖
圖就是連續劇
對 連續的看嘛
裡面都是寶貝
都是你賺錢的機會
好 所以老師提醒你囉
我們看一張線圖
會比看八點檔還精彩
今天先教你們最基本的
KD值喔
不曉得你們有沒有跟趙華一樣
很驚訝的發現
趙華以前一直以為
KD值要到二十 我才能進場
不是喔
今天有告訴你
KD值有時候五六十
黃金交叉向上的時候
反而代表還是強勢骨
那不曉得你學到了沒
如果過去你有一些對KD紙比較模糊的
或是錯誤的想法
其實我相信今天這堂課
一定給你滿滿的新的知識
而且讓你操作的勝率大幅提高
那我們今天謝謝朱家昂老師
李才宅的台南秀
下次再見囉 拜拜
謝謝大家 拜拜
字幕製作人Zither Harp